its founders hope it will become the
Guggenheim of wines the 80 million euro
CT devel in the heart of france's wine
capital Baldo this week
the exhibition inside the building open
to the public we will surprise many
people because we say we're not a museum
we don't have our own collection
the name city or city doesn't give much
away you can already see that from the
response of the first visitor the
exterior is designed to make people
curious and then inside comes the
surprise the exhibits are interactive
and digital the show is divided into 19
different themes which visitors are
invited to experience for themselves by
trying things out rather than just
reading the facts one of the highlights
is the buffet of the senses seeing
touching smelling visitors are taught
the A to Z of wine tasting we had a
brief from the client for the
competition that was originally about
365 pages long it was a big thick brief
and it was full of scientific content
and a lot of very kind of nerdy wine
information some very dense information
so our challenge really was to try and
make it entertaining for the general
public so to take the seriousness and
the study that had done behind the
content actually make it fun for wine is
Bordeaux's number one export the city
has flourished for centuries thanks to
the wine trade and wine is very much a
part of life here
expert vini and teaches locals and
tourists more about the region's wines
but double duel in people's minds
both in France and abroad the name
Bordeaux is seen as a mark of quality
you immediately think of grand old
chateaus and vineyards people come here
especially for the wines but then of
course there's also the local expertise
every year Bordeaux's vineyards produce
over four and a half million barrels of
red white and fortified wines some of
the very best wines come from the
Chateau OTE vineyard the unique sound
ales is in charge here one of the very
few top women vintners she says there
are good reasons why Bordeaux is known
internationally for its quality wines
vineyards are located on the 45th
parallel it said that all the best wine
growing areas are located at this
latitude they're clearly geological and
meteorological conditions that allow for
these great vineyards but that's not all
wine growing is a real art you need
expertise and the right touch you gotta
the shuttle OTE uses old traditional
methods for producing its wines most of
which are exported but the work of the
vintners has nevertheless changed over
time these days they don't just make
wine in dark cellars they also explain
their work to visitors we have always
had visitors who are interested in our
work it's great for Bordeaux and this
kind of tourism has increased since the
city was declared a UNESCO World
Heritage Site we're getting more and
more visitors at the city due down those
visitors can learn about the production
and history of wine and explore their
own personal tastes while this room
allows visitors to experience the sense
of being intoxicated without alcohol
just through music and projected images
we're not necessarily turning people
into experts
we're in lots of ways we're actually
trying to tell you that your taste is
individual and you and you shouldn't be
intimidated by expertise but
nevertheless there's this 6,000 years of
culture and the more that you start to
try and understand about that the more
interesting wine becomes in the bar on
the top floor of the city too though
visitors can sample different wines from
all over the world while enjoying a
panoramic view of Bordeaux